[Music]
the child i ate in the womb in a past
life is here
she made it and i crawled my way out um
let me okay first of all are we friends
that's how i start the podcast
um
yeah
i'm like yeah maybe
a little
um no yes how do we what's our how do we
identify
this relationship chaotic
identifies
super chaotic indeed emotionally broken
a little dumb tremendous um so you are
we got to work together
under very weird circumstances we did we
made a pilot together it was i was also
playing like a 25 year old at 17. none
of it really made sense i'm not 25 i was
playing like 22. yeah i was like a
junior or senior you were in co yeah you
were like but you could be smart and
that's true
well is that where we are now 25 year
olds have to pay 25 year olds and 17
year olds i actually i have a lot of
friends when i was like watching 90210
those motherfuckers were all 62. no they
are oh no literally i was on glee where
it was like the arp club and i was i was
the only 13 year old yeah it's like have
you seen the movie grease olivia and
john is 54. well but she's saying high
school i have so many friends that are
like 30 but they play 15 and 16 and it's
like that's what they do to catch a
predator it's home yeah
they take like 18 year olds it's a whole
process the audition process for the
kids that are the bait on to catch a
predator is to me so much creepier than
the actual pedophiles
can we we need a bunch of 18 year olds
that look 15 like who decides that they
look 13 strange it's like a bunch of
guys like yeah she looks 13 yeah i agree
yeah totally let's hire her it's like i
don't like this process of casting the
girl
yeah yeah no that sounds it sounds like
something you should stop
we're taking a real quick break from uh
this dazzling conversation with josie
where i feel like i'm more charming than
normal is that even possible what do you
think yeah i yeah
okay
emily is high this morning and i cannot
get enough of it i want to talk to you
real quick about performance apparel
because you know that i'm a total brat
about what i put on my body what i put
in my body that's another story what i
put on it very very picky as three
people that struggle with various mental
illnesses we are authorities on
comfortable clothes
no one knows more about sweatpants than
us okay
these are perfect if you're sick and
tired of traditional old workout gear
that grabs you in all the wrong places
this is the perfect thing to put on your
body if you're going to work out or if
you're doing like everyday life things
like taking a bunch of edibles and
passing out on a couch or coming to work
whichever you prefer also i need to be
able to go from the gym straight to do
stand up at night i'm not gonna do a
wardrobe change i don't have that kind
of time so fiori is super cute because
you can just like i'll put my flats on
like i'll have my like sweatpants i'll
work out on them and then i'll be able
to like just put a cute top with it like
a denim shirt and like there you are
effortlessly chic and also in shape chic
and in shape fiore is an investment in
your happiness for our listeners they
are offering 20 off your first purchase
get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet keep going them heads calm
whitney that's v-u-o-r-i
dot com slash whitney not only will you
receive 20 off your first purchase but
enjoy free shipping on any us orders
over 75 dollars and free returns go to
yori.com whitney and discover the
versatility of yori clothing
when inserting the link into the show
make enjoy the show
guys
this is not she's not speaking english
anymore this is
[Laughter]
the fact that you got home last night
and decided to work wait yeah what is
something i didn't pass on on it on a
bike i'm gonna have to watch that but
yeah we can't do it it's really easy
okay that was just our in content
pre-roll we're gonna trim that down way
much tight okay
way much tight
so fucking hot should we
enjoy the show oh my god
wait
make enjoy the show
on may 20th i'm going to be at tyson's
corner of virginia at the capital one
hall as you guys might have heard i did
spend a lot of time after school at
tyson's corner with my mom she worked at
bloomingdale's and i shoplifted a lot of
stuff so in the mall jail so i will be
back to apologize to you for that
uh on may 21st i'm gonna be in the
huntington new york area at the
paramount theater
get
googling june 24th calgary alberta
prince island park june 26th i'll be in
toronto on date at the danforth music
hall oh my gosh rescheduled shows how do
i do these shows i don't know i have
can't even read them i don't know how to
go there to these towns and pet all my
wares but i'm coming september 8th
cincinnati ohio we rescheduled uh at the
taft theater september 9th i mean
philadelphia pennsylvania at the merriam
theater
september 10th i'll be in richmond
virginia at the national september 24th
i will be in charlottesville virginia at
the paramount theater back to josie tota
for some fascinating vocal fry
um
one of the hardest times i've laughed in
the last couple years was me and you on
set and me just saying
things that i love and her having really
like
this is one of my favorite things okay
ready speed round i'm so excited lisa
loeb
uh
uh
oh
sounds like um
i don't know i only know lisa
i don't know who that is uh hanson
and gretel
evan i don't know
evan hansen um hanson drew barrymore yes
of course i of course i know her um
helen hunt
of
that's a great last name
i just want to yell that name like helen
hunt
i don't know
yes i do know him um but i i feel like
i've seen him in his car
on like the 101.
i've seen him in person i don't know
anything i don't know
um
tony braxton
yes i'm not uncultured
third eye blind
oh
was it english uh who was that english
what did i say like that what is it like
i was british um montel jordan yes
really yes i do well we had well yes
he's famous but also see now but the
helen hunt just jumped off a bridge
i'm sorry you okay okay and then who are
your heroes like i'm obsessed with who
you guys look up to
um
my heroes
are um people that i think are uh
like because we had heroes and i'm
trying to think videos are canceled i
don't really like up to anyone like
michael jordan
oh yeah you know everyone's private
lives yeah can people be heroes anymore
because you've seen their old tweets i
think they can't be my friends they're
like obsessed with miley cyr sorry
that's miley cyrus and like people like
that yeah i love her um
she's so cool like whoopi goldberg
is an old reference i love the view can
we talk about my niche love for the
video yes i watch it every day like a
white woman in like suburb florida what
except white ones in southern florida
aren't watching the view they're
watching like fox i don't know i said
that that was a bad reference no i mean
no
district or like granite bay or like
somewhere i don't know what
about the view is the first time i met
whoopi goldberg by the way i cried which
i see
i cried on the view
and they had to cut it like it wasn't
like i shut down i couldn't make a
sentence you ruined the show i went and
i was this was so dumb it was the first
time i'd ever done like press like i'm
on a tv show it's the first time i've
done the view i'm like doing letterman
i'm doing all these shows and it's first
time i had a stylist and the stylist got
i was wearing a top it was green and
then it had like spikes on the shoulders
like spiky like that was the style that
it was like a spiky whatever it was like
punk rock whatever and i'll put on a
blouse and i go in and i give her like
the biggest hug
and she's like ah like i'm stabbing her
with my shirt
and because i had a spiky shirt on and i
was like i hold on to her so tightly and
then i started crying and then i like
wouldn't let her go because i was like
if i let go everyone's gonna see that
i'm crying so i was like can you just
keep hugging me and she's like i can't
do this for much longer
and then i had a full meltdown oh uh i
also she gave me a pair of shoes it was
an episode they're here then she brought
me into her dressing room gave me a pair
of her i also was brought into her
dressing room
and her shoe
because she thought you were me her she
thought we were the same she thought it
was just she did um her shoe game is
like real people don't know that and
then um
whoopi goldberg uh have you seen her uh
fart on the view
yes i have it is
unreal our experience post 911 and it's
our identity was really questioned and i
think it explores that in a really smart
way
the subject is nine eleven i know that's
kind of like the worst time to let out
but also you've seen ghosts
of course yeah that was the first film
i've ever seen in my life really yes i
had a really weird start off the first
movie i ever saw was ghost and the
second was the green mile so like this
is
do we know all styles
i think the first documentary i watched
was like the jc lee do card
documentary where she was like kidnapped
for 18 years oh yeah i feel yeah yeah
and i like was convinced i was going to
be said
you're not professional six months
right i know that'd be nice there is a
company that you can pay to kidnap you i
do see there's like those games that you
can do too where you like they torture
you which i'm talking about they bring
you into a cabin and they like touch you
and grab you and like a do-word shit
yeah and anyway i'm just you should do
that my exes will do that for free okay
to any of you but yeah no that is
awesome yeah no that is a hollywood
agency um i think it's what you're
talking about hold on i have all these
questions for you i don't want to forget
all that okay more
heroes like who because you can't really
ask for us it was athlete when you look
back at the people we used to look up to
it's so wild it was like athletes and
you now are like pronounced like people
were just really beautiful
and like also have good morals yeah like
zoe kravitz for instance yes yes yes
like she's like so like the most
beautiful person on planet earth and she
is a good has good morals i feel like
you being in the business for as long as
you've been in i feel like you probably
have like an incredible antenna on
people
yeah what are like red flags in people
where you're like this is so many so
many red flags especially in la there's
like social climbing red flags like you
just like feel it yeah what really makes
you angry i can't picture you being like
angry like when do you lose your temper
that's right it's so easy really yeah
it is like what give me once last time
you were like
i'm in the i'm yelling in the car
i'm yelling in the car and everyone on
the road yeah exactly right right i'm
actually someone who enjoys the
stupidity of valerie drivers like a lot
of people my mom thinks that like la is
where like stupid just like is attracted
to it like it comes to drive in l.a but
i actually like how stupid people drive
here and i'm like used to it because i
learned how to drive here yeah and so
being in a i go to school in like a
regular
suburb
full of like normies and they drive in a
way that is like volatile to me and it
makes me extremely angry it's like full
stop at the stop sign uh blinker on to
turn right uh and it's like stop at the
red light to turn right it's
so it's truly traumatizing to me though
people that do that that are the dorks
that follow the rules that hard i'm like
you are
um uh like a criminal that started a new
life and you can't afford any tickets
true that's so true to me i'm like if i
get a parking ticket i don't give a fuck
if i run this five days like i'm like oh
my god that's i literally at this point
at my my school i've gotten over three
thousand dollars in parking tickets i'm
like paying for valet that's what i've
like
waited
so interesting like i will because i
refuse to park in the main garage
because i have crippling and that's also
another thing people don't know i have
bad anxiety around people i don't know
like i'm like i'm either overzealous and
overconfident but like no one knows that
i'm like wanting to die inside and can i
ask you is that something that is um
new you've always known about it and
i've always known about it but i used to
be rude when i had anxiety now i just
get
ever since i just became a fucking woman
i get really sad and just wanted you
know yeah welcome thank you
it's no longer like angry it's just like
sad but and is it do you think it has to
do with your specific like journey or no
i just think i'm just a very like i like
feeling comfortable and i don't i'm
confident around and you've seen me in
big groups i'm like very comfortable
outwardly but inside i just want to die
because yeah i think a lot of like a lot
of people i know especially performers
it's like we're comfortable around
everyone i
for me
i just feel for here's what i will say
most people are duds
most people are succubus vampires beauty
energy people that are emotionally
exhausting yeah so i'm always like i
have anxiety i have social anxiety it's
like most people are just also no most
people are awful i just like yeah i
don't want to be that's so true i don't
want to be around a lot of people but i
also i love being around a lot of people
it makes no sense i'm constantly at odds
with myself every conversation i get in
the first thing that comes in my head is
how am i going to get out of this every
conversation about that the second i
make plans every conversation i've ever
been in with anyone yeah there's like i
have to plan my escape and i'm like
doing like action actually
i will like i'll plan an arc i will in
that moment in my head to try to like
give this person what they need to feel
happy so i could go away right right
right yeah people i like crush on a guy
what's the like how what's the fastest
way out of this nightmare
yeah that's that's the concept
but is it mine is when it's with when
someone tries to make small talk what is
my fastest way out i'm not like when
someone when will when is the
conversation working because i also know
my things because it's also i'm like
it's my responsibility to control a
conversation if i have to have one and
set a boundary and if you think i'm a
bitch fine because you already think
that so i i that ship has sailed there's
something so
uh liberating about people already
thinking you're a bitch right because
then you're just like i can't control
this i'm a loud woman that's kind of
shrill and i have a pain you already
think i'm a cunt so i might as well just
roll with this and small talk i cannot
do if i
can't either i hate it makes me think
you're stealing my life for me i'd
rather you just like scream a slur at me
than like ask me how i'm doing like i'm
more comfortable in that response and
this is the other thing about me and
alicia he's my best friend like we will
go out to events and parties and she is
so sweet and wants to know about your
life story and like cares about and so
we all be like on our way to like pick
up pizza and like there's an hour-long
conversation on like i don't know santa
monica boulevard of her and this random
person that we just met and it's like
then i'm the asshole if i'm like okay
but we need to get the pizza so then
it's like but then she really cares
about this person so then i'm like
should i care about this person and then
i find myself like diving into the convo
and i'm like no i don't give a fuck
about this person i care about you i
want to get my fucking pizza and so then
i just found myself being like but we
really need to get the pizza and then i
just make up something like i don't know
we're in a crisis
something you can say that no one can
fuck with is that when people um like
want to take your energy just going like
i'm at capacity right now i'm so sorry
right i know i can't do that i just
thought you if you get there there is
such a
amazing magical thing you can do because
you're just like that's so true because
you can't be mad at someone we're saying
no you can't and then there's this like
they're like oh my god me too like it
gives everyone permission to stop
bullshit because we humans like we have
this need to just fill
silence with drivel and everyone's
obsession with logistics emily and i
were just talking about this have you
been to a wedding lately
like in the summer this summer yeah and
every wedding i've ever been to i'm like
i get so angry because people only want
to talk about how you got there and how
you're going to leave right so you're at
a wedding like trying to have a good
time i was at a mormon wedding so it was
oh yeah not on playing by normal playing
were there three brides
there no there was one cube she was
she's a good friend her name was sabrina
she's beautiful but it was a very
interesting experience i bet it was like
24 hours in utah and there was a whole
journey um but you get to the
the wedding and it's just like where'd
you come in from
right right it's like you're like uh new
york laguardia
no you know what newark if you go to
newark it's actually fast and then
everyone needs to give you their travel
tips that's so true and then it's okay
so you can and then
and then as soon as you finish that 40
minute conversation that there's a train
did you take the tram down oh but if you
check luggage it took longer and then
now the ubers now you can't they don't
pull up there's like a waiting area so
did you do the uber i'm a
so do you know uber is like there's a
weird thing when you sign in you can't
sue them so now i'm just
stabbing myself and then as soon as you
you're like all right i give gave this
person my itinerary that i just did
there how are you going back sunday
sunday yeah you're gonna go back sunday
what time which oh what's your flight
are you on yeah i'm on the two o'clock
oh you're on the why don't you what kind
of plane i was telling emily there's
always one person at the wedding that
needs you to change your flight so you
can ride with them
that is just so
fucking selfish or anyone has anyone
ever asked you to take them to the
airport i'm like why would you ask me
that people know better but no i
understand about but the
weddings emily had a friend in town
recently and she drove over to the
airport and it made me so angry it
fucked up my whole sunday emily was like
i'm driving my front of the airport and
i was like it's like a six-hour thing i
can't no i can't i like because when
someone is like hey were you driving to
the airport i'm like let do you just not
want to be friends
anymore do you fucking
watch that like there's we just can call
it right you know that's exactly how i
feel i think it's extremely
disrespectful
i will get you an uber like just 100
i would rather pay for yeah car service
like a 400 car for service and take the
time out of my day to drive you to an
airport you selfish fucking bitch is the
guy that needs you to change your flight
at the wedding the same guy that needs
to give everyone a back massage
it's like i i'm now i just really i'm
trying no i feel like that's the guy
that asks for one the older you get the
more
what do you mean the older you get the
more you're able to really put people
into categories like i think that's so
true i was able to
one of my favorite things what's your
girl scout cookie emily i was like
shortbread
i know she's the short red bitch i'm
obsessed with this the things that
you're able to kind of just tell about
somebody so you your cookie
you i feel like you're you have some
system where you're like it's thin mints
but i put them in the fridge and then
put them on ice cream like you've got a
thing i am i
live my life around food like i plan my
life around i live to eat and i live for
dinner it's a marathon until dinner so
i'm eating like a like a fucking little
bird until dinner comes because you want
to wait then i'm like the space yes and
then i'm like the rock like i am i go in
there's no way poland is intact when i
don't know when you look at the rock's
cheat meals on his instagram it's insane
it's like upsetting it's crazy
it's balls to the wall but i do plan my
life around dinner so i am very much
like that when it comes to cookies and
stuff like it needs to be in a specific
way
or else i'm i need to enjoy it something
needs to be playing i need all sensory
yeah i'm very weary like that see i
g you'd eat in the car on the you deep
throated
bar even when i eat in the car it's like
a full thing i have to be listening to a
podcast or like i can't listen to music
while i eat i used to when i had
weird ass eating disorders when i first
moved to la i would only eat like
fat-free frozen yogurt and i would go
get it like that was the thing which is
like so much worse with eating oh my
gosh everyone eating disorders we would
just
eat all this fat there was like tasty
delight there was like blizzard for it
was just all
aspartame and just like nonsense trash
it was just chemical eating chemicals
and uh i started balding i my my
ponytail was like a little rat tail that
smells like i have gotta eat something
that has come from the ground and uh i
could only eat it if i had just took a
shower
that is so i would go you know take a
shower put my hair in a bun i do have a
weird thing i like wouldn't obviously
liken it to an eating disorder obviously
but i do have a weird thing where i
can't eat unless my piece clear
every morning you can't because someone
told me that once i can't eat unless my
pee is clear in the morning so i won't
consume food unless i've drank enough
water to the point where my urine is
clear
otherwise i get anxiety my
urine has been neon
yellow that horrifies me i think for
that changes my mood i would be
concerned it's it's just like
yeah i need to drink more water but i
also there is a case to be made that i'm
involved
well people say they're like you have
sweet skin it's like i think it's just
an embalming of chemicals honestly i was
well you don't have that scent yet
which is what with the death and bomb
scent when you wake up in the morning
what is your what is your like morning
routine everyone hates me i don't wash
my face unless i have makeup on i only
wash my face if it's oil and i never uh
water on my face i use an oil and then i
use a regular cleanser and that's all
and then lotion and that's all i do yeah
this is why we look like we are made by
the damn tubes literally fetuses you
never should wash your face
okay that's if you have eye makeup on
take up all your makeup but i only use
oil and i'll then i'll put oil on
water oil again derma roll clean there's
no need to ever like scrub when i wake
up i'm just brushing my teeth and that's
what i wash my hands before i don't wash
my face so i'll wash my hands and then
put oil on oh 100 seconds to wash your
hands i've washed my hands at least if
i'm out and i go home i've washed my
hands at least three times before
touching my face because i'm afraid
i'm not a germ person but i'm afraid huh
like i will dance on like i don't know
like a weight staff at a club but i will
be afraid to like put a finger on my
face if i'm taking i can't i used to
have such a phobia about people touching
my face like grabbing touching oh i hate
that i couldn't like i don't like hugs
in that way too especially if i'm like
have my hair and makeup done i'm like
why don't we need to do that i got so
much shit because i was at the comedy
store one night and you go and i was
like is this just a because i'm a girl
everyone's hugging me hug me and i said
i was like guys can we i see you every
day like i don't need to hug like can we
just stop them is awesome because girls
do it too they come at you and i'm like
hi they do and they grab your hair when
they're like doing that like we don't
need to do this it's such a an awkward
it's so good i've been told that i'm
like a really bad hugger in the past but
i've gotten better than people are
saying but it's just because i don't
care like i'm not putting an effort to
hug you because i don't want to i just i
want to look you in the eye and i don't
want to i don't know what you're doing
right like what you're up to like you
know it's too close yeah i agree it's
too close it's too close also i um it
makes me uncomfortable it makes me
secure about my breath um but also the
uh other thing about small talk i think
you also can take control of the
situation if you have to that's my new
thing with social anxiety is i'm just
like
where are you from what's your ancestry
like i need to learn something do you
listen to a podcast 100 i'm the same in
that way like i need something specific
about your life also i have a really bad
problem if i'm in small talk with
someone and they haven't complained
about something or like mentioned like a
struggle that they've had whether it was
like as simple as something that
happened that day or just in general
like people were just like even killed
and like fine i'm like i don't trust you
yeah i don't like you you're hiding
something yeah exactly it's like what
are you i also think you have to fuck
with people that have the same kind of
inherited or life trauma in a way
because you agree on what is annoying
what is traumatic like when i'm talking
to somebody like oh my god the most
traumatic i was on the freeway and like
i couldn't get here and i'm like
traumatized and you're like that's not
drama yeah we'll never we have different
definitions so true like i can't talk to
you about this there's so many people
that are so
yeah i don't want to say shallow in that
regard because it is traumatic to them
but it's also just like i don't know i
can't really one of my favorite things
though um kathy griffin i've told you
this that um uh we were like at dinner
one time this was like eight ten years
ago she was like if you're in la
and you're walking down the street as a
famous person
any stranger around you look at them and
say congratulations and they'll always
say thank you
so kathy griffin is like walking down
hollywood boulevard and like just some
random like you know girl like 25 she's
like hey hey hey hey oh my god
congratulations and the girl's like
thank you thank you so much like did it
took five or six people they kathy said
that to her they no kathy griffin a
famous person yeah yeah said she's just
a random conversation hey oh my god hey
what's up congratulations i just heard
and i was like thank you that is so
everyone said she was like i watched
this and i was like there's no way ever
everyone hands down
uh basically thanked a famous person for
acknowledging their
callback they're i don't know like
that's so funny that's amazing it was so
funny so it's also i do i do get
fascinated by uh watching people just
talk about themselves and think they're
more interesting than they are yeah
that's true i do like yeah
but self-destruction but i also like to
just be like i also
i'm not reading news as much anymore and
i like to get my news from complete
change
what's going on like it's a great way to
like get just because no one knows
source it's all the people that think
they have the most opinions they're like
yeah um russia's uh invading ukraine i'm
like like why and they're like um like i
love watching people who think they
don't just slowly deteriorate as you ask
them more questions it's yes that is
like 90 of the people at my university
taking a quick break from the brilliant
josie toto to talk real quick about
mental wealth let's go life can be
overwhelming it's a nightmare and people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless trap detachment fatigue
and
more better help is customized online
therapy offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
except us that's i'm all for that no i'm
sure
there's a lot of audio only people
uh it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy which is awesome and
uh you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours you guys know all this
here's the thing you know you know
better help is a product that would
change your life what's what's what's
what's holding you back what is it
fear fear is that it yeah well guess
what
compat your fear with ten percent off
your first month at better health still
scared
betterhelp.com
whitney
shaking in your boots there are so many
bugs in here there's there's there's so
many so disrupting i'm sorry that during
uh my like someone is going like yeah i
should try therapy and i'm just grabbing
bugs
you're like why am i taking mental
health advice from someone that's just
punching me
so i know that i don't seem like a
person you'd want to take mental health
advice from right now because i am crap
but there are bugs and we're all so many
we all promise each other that we all
can see them they're like fruit flies
i feel like they're fruit
i think i just got a bunch of them so
anyway i'm sorry that that's better help
betterhdlp.com
this show is brought to you by better
help back to josie and then um okay so
more red flags
um that of people that i mean um
yeah like if they don't have any trauma
but also dating
okay but also over sharing is also a red
flag 100 on a date if someone's telling
you and i was molested and i had this or
they're over complimenting and like love
bombing yeah major red flag yeah they're
like you're so i had someone i was
talking to someone for like it was a few
months and he was like you're you've
become one of the most more people in my
life i was like and my housekeeper is
closer to me than you i like don't know
anything about you and i hate when
people think that they're closer to you
than than you are to them that's right
that's a red flag very big red flag so
if we're not on the same page about how
we know each other yeah and like
grandiose gestures and like i can't live
without you and those are all right
it's like all right well i've been
waiting for you no you haven't like just
all that shit but i also think it's
tricky because i mean
we've also been programmed to like say
that stuff do you know what i mean from
like how else do you like true you also
don't want someone to be like hey i love
you
it doesn't mean that you're a bad person
it just means that you have toxic
tendencies and it's maybe it's not on
purpose yeah but it's unintentional and
i think that can happen when people love
bomb or they over compliment or they do
big gestures and gifts and stuff like my
roommate had a guy send her a she said
she like cheese quesadillas once and
this man sent her a fucking cheese
quesadilla every single night post made
it to her house he was living in a
different state is he single now he was
in alaska you are the most ungrateful
generation every single day a postman
cheese quesadilla then when they would
get angry he would be like well i'm not
gonna give you a fucking quesadilla like
he was using the quesadillas over her
and trying to like send her gifts and
stuff center toilet paper honestly
i'm starting to think this was a
gentleman i am looking for is this a
prince no but it's an assistant that
loves logistics he's this person
available but that's that's weird
because it's like i don't know in some
level that's a very romantic gesture i
think that we're innocent with romance i
do that should it's really toxic if it's
the wrong person it's really romantic if
it's the right person i think also too
when i was younger i felt like i needed
to pay for things to like not make
people like me but just like i do that
now too just to like establish dominance
i feel like oh yes even in big groups
like i was at a diner after a birthday
party the other day and for some reason
like when the bill came there was like
20 of us i was just like i'll cover it
and no one like looked at me like oh
you're fucking cool for covering this
diner bell there's like eight burgers on
the table but for some reason i felt
like i needed to
and then i get the bill and i spent 300
on burgers for no reason and like
there's a cockroach on the floor and i
don't even support this establishment so
but no one offered to pay or you were
like i got it no they were like we can
pay and i had to be like oh no it's fine
and then they were like
but we can and i was just like no and
then i got like rude about it
yeah because once you offer you can't i
know
but maybe that's also the arab and me
like having to cover everything making
sure everyone's taken care of but then
the other thing is not everyone is like
that or was raised like that because i
was raised to always cover but to me for
the longest time money was the thing
that was most valued in my when you grew
up without it it's a big deal right and
then so as soon as i started making
money especially because all my friends
for the longest time covered me like
paid my parking tickets like help me out
like i had seven dollars for eight years
and like all my so now that i like have
whenever we go out i'll like pay and
it's the over correction thing and my
friend nikki from college um every time
we go out i would like pay and she
finally was like this is weird stop like
stop right like you're me it feels weird
it does feel weird and it's going to the
point now where my bestest friends we
don't really get each other gifts
because we're like why would we do that
yeah like we could buy it ourselves uh
yes if there's something like toxic
about the score keeping and stuff that's
such a weird toxic older thing like we
have to get gifts we have to do the
thing like doing things yeah we don't do
gifts anymore and i love that or just
give it to give trash it's an experience
where i'm like let me fly this person
out that you love and that you don't
know that's coming so that you can come
and see let me not give you more clutter
exactly if i hate that i hate i hate
getting yes but i also don't love either
the this is hot take the i'm gonna make
a donation in your name that's the like
wedding registries there's a new thing
you don't i just assume that you like
lied about that well oh no they no no no
no no they emailed because there was one
a charity there was like two to choose
from or something and there were just
charities that i was like i donate to
charities a lot these are just not i
most charities are fucking scams like i
guess that's great but it's like that's
for you babe it's not for me but i know
i know
that these chairs like you go on like
what is a charity finder or something
you can see how much they pay their ceos
like i'm very like
skeptical of charities and uh because
i'm like well this one pays their ceo
three hundred and eighty thousand
dollars a year like this we're just
you're you're getting scammed we're all
getting tamed it's like um and uh no
they were like hey we noticed you
haven't donated someone emailed it's
been a year or whatever
yeah i got called out damn yeah but it's
but then it's like if that's what you
want i guess it's better than buying
like bowls or plates or some shit but it
is uh as i get older it's like gifts are
so weird they're so weird like if you
want to get someone something i'll just
do it any time of the year yeah and 100
especially when family members want to
give you gifts it's just like i don't
even want that from you yeah because now
i it well then now i have to perform and
like i don't like it the way you want me
to like right now i have to wear this
shirt every time that's a nice view yeah
but no
but to me i my big thing with gifts is
like i feel like i'm giving you a
re-gift for someone else so it's like
i'm gonna give you a great nicely
wrapped candle right you know what it is
and when you're in a jam you can just
give it to someone else gifting is a
very big part of my family
system
and it's not weird i don't yeah gifting
is big with my family too like my sister
loves getting gifts like she loves like
i swear to god we've bought her like the
entire
line of like david yerman that's like
500 and below
um and
that's all that she has she like is
obsessed with david yerman it's like
she's living in 2010. i don't know why
david yerman is she's like 20 years old
i don't know why she's obsessed with
david german it's hard to explain david
yerman is um it's like a record it's
like a russian
uh
someone's russian second wife's favorite
jewelry
it's very gaudy in a very uh
90s way yeah but i feel like it's kind
of the point where it's like is it camp
it's what is it camp now that it's like
it's like it's like you know it's like
bracelets that have yeah i know this
stuff is cute but i think it was a hot
tape it's kind of like if ed hardy did
jewelry
that is so spot on right
like it's a little there's like a cross
for no reason within reason it just
looks cheap in a weird way but it's
really expensive
and like growing up in dc it was like
all the
like rich wives like it was all about
david yerman right but it's like a giant
yellow stone but i'm also i'm just not a
jewelry person
i won't wear anything nice unless i'm
being paid to wear it's been given to me
because i'm like i want to spend money
on my car and my home yes and places
that i go smart not like i'll wear like
a paper cloth over my crotch in a bra
and i go to class in that because i just
don't have time to pay for clothes there
is something i'm definitely i'm not a
crystal person um but i i sometimes
crystals are so expensive for no reason
for no reason what are you paying for
it's like find god not an object yeah
where are you where do you stand with
god does it vibrate oh god i'm sorry
dude crystal sex toys is a whole
thing i'm sure
um yeah that's me but that's where it
makes sense to me that's a purpose yeah
i mean it's just letting it sit in your
corner and praying that'll like cure
your depression
my thing with that is like they are
pretty and they put me in a good mood
i'm not saying it's i'm not charging
them my thing with crystals is like yeah
they're healing because they're just
pretty looking and that's great i think
if that makes you happy that's totally
fine for me it doesn't bring objects
don't bring me joy in that way so unless
i'm like using it for a purpose unless
something which is something that like i
do struggle with is like making sure
everything has a purpose or like if i'm
doing something i'm like is this
productive yeah i'm grateful for my like
strong work ethic but it's the point
where i'm not doing anything during the
day i have to convince myself that it's
okay to like just be still and like be
alone and like not have to make
everything something that is like
productive or that i've accomplished
something like accomplishing can just be
resting do you think that's our are kind
of most of your friends like that i mean
i'm sure you attract people similar to
you yeah that's a lot of people my age
self-deprivation whatever and just like
recognizing pain and stress and
exhaustion as success is something that
i've had to
like i used to you know get off set and
if i wasn't like exhausted to the point
where i was like on the brink of death
like knocking on death's door
i would i would feel like oh i didn't
work hard enough today i used to think
it was like cool like it was yeah i mean
it was like
myself it's like who slept the least and
it was like this culture of like oh my
god i'm so tired i'm exhausted i'm so
sick i've been sick for two weeks i've
had a migraine for two weeks like no one
thinks that's cool like why where did i
get that idea yeah destroying my health
it was like that was my last year
towards the end of last year
i was very much in that mindset and i
was like filming
a show and i was also really involved in
school and like organizations and stuff
on campus and like i was literally
running shit at school until like 2 a.m
and then having to go to work at 6 00
a.m in la drive back work a 14-hour day
and then go home and do the same thing
again and i was so constantly ill and
then this year i was like i'm going to
get sleep i'm going to eat i'm going to
schedule as best as i can and like try
to stay on track yeah and it's helped a
lot i'm doing tremendously better than
than i was doing yeah it is weird though
everyone really wants to like reward it
it's like it's like um
you know like having eating disorders
back day or when you're like sick and
you get really skinny it's like you look
amazing you're like oh my god all these
like sick things are so rewarded like
toxic niceness too is so rewarded as
well yeah you know the idea of like if
you take care of yourself you're a bitch
it's also like well you're giving you're
martyring yourself for this like if i'm
tired and get sick this whole production
shuts down like me not sleeping eight
hours is like selfish and benefits right
right
yeah no exactly and that's why i've had
to change my mindset can you vacation or
like relax
um i can do it if i'm if i'm with other
people yeah and now ever since covet
because
i mean that time that i got coved in
like last september
was the very first time i was alone
for
i can't even remember for years i had
never been alone for that long in my
entire life because i was quarantining
for 10 days in my bedroom
um like everyone else was and so i
didn't realize like this is the first
time i've i've ever been alone the
entire summer while i was shooting
season two of stay with a bell i had two
people living in my room one in my bed
one on my floor there were two of my
best friends
and um i like could not remember the
last time that i had showered alone like
showered
i'm like having orgies showered where
there wasn't someone like yeah in and
out of my hallway or like in my bathroom
doing something and i love these people
but
kovid forced me to find comfortability
in my
lonesomeness and to find enjoyment in
that and
is it like you know is it liking just
the distraction or just knowing that
you're safe it's like not having to yeah
not having to be
with yourself and me feeling like being
by myself wasn't enough because it's
like my productive thing like to me
being productive is like i had lunch
with this person had a great
conversation and yeah i'm glad that i
caught up with them or like there's so
many people in my phone check that off
my list exactly it's like i have one
less thing on my plate and it feels like
when you're alone you're not really
accomplishing much in my head that's
what i initially thought but then it's
like no i actually did accomplish a lot
because i spent time with myself and i
journaled or watched movie or i played
piano or whatever restored myself got
perspective
you know and also we need contrast like
i find like you know the less time i
spend with the guy that i'm dating the
more i enjoy when i'm with him i'm more
present yeah instead of if like we're
always just kind of talking the quality
of the hang is so low yeah that it's
like by the time we sit and have dinner
i'm like we've all we've kind we've
half-assed this all day i'd rather just
not see you all day and then be
yeah for an hour be like 100 presents
because i'll half-ass a bunch of so and
then it doesn't count you know because
it's a shitty quality behind this is so
recent for me um
it kind of happened a little bit after
my dad died and i did ayahuasca uh
and then like a couple i like was like
i'd micro i don't know if this did
anything micro dosing mushrooms i don't
know i i don't know or maybe just
getting older i love hanging out with
myself yeah it is
so fun to me i do too know especially
since i know that most of my thoughts
are science fiction and not my voice and
other people's because you when i
thought my voice inner voice was was
true you're a piece of shit you're
falling behind you're never gonna make
it you've wasted your life everybody
hates you you're ugly like now that i
know that's none of that's true it's
kind of like funny to me to get heckled
by my inner bully and be like oh my god
like that's it's like right i have a
different relationship with my mind now
because it used to be this haunted house
that was like constantly bullying me and
whatever and like now i'm able to go
like a lot of it is you're falling
behind you're falling behind like if i
the second i lay my head down for a nap
or to meditate or take care of myself if
you're falling behind you piece of shit
like you're self-indulgent like you
don't deserve this there's so many
people like your privilege like all the
shit whatever yeah
you complain you're sensitive you need
to work harder you're lazy like i'm able
to now just be like
that's like funny to me to think that
you thought that at one point and like
that kind of got me here like i can
that's like my annoying friend that's
like still giving me bad advice but like
i'm not gonna get rid of them i'm able
to just go like you're nuts you know
i'm glad you got to that point i feel
like that's i feel like i'm not all the
way there but i'm definitely now like
starting to enjoy being by myself in a
way that i never have before doing
nothing is an action and it took me so
long it's an active choice it's not like
and i'm learning
there's so many things that happen that
i don't process like we need processing
time yeah i mean that's so true and you
learned so much just by being still in a
way that i didn't realize yeah it's just
in a way that's like okay all these
things happen i ran into this person
like what does that mean how what what
did i like i just you have to catch up
it's like updating your software it's
like all this stuff happened now i'm
gonna integrate it into my hippocampus
i'm gonna process it i'm gonna like
go yeah i should see that person more
like why what are these choices i'm
making it's like in 12-step programs we
do a ten step every night where you
basically just like run through your day
and you go like do i own an apology did
i do anything today that was like zombie
old like stinking thinking bullshit like
did i revert to some old uh you know
defense mechanism that's boring did i
like complain too much was i negative oh
i love that you just like go through and
it's a lot of it is do i own apology to
anybody or do i own apology myself or or
do i
did i nail it here's the cool things i
did it out here the things i want to i
want to keep behaving like this or like
i wasn't super proud of doing that like
down to like
why don't i have my fucking refillable
water bottle today i drank three plastic
water bottle you know i need to start
putting the water bottle by my bed so i
wake up like any systems that need to be
changed whatever and then i'll like
visualize my next day and like
it
what it does
when i don't do it
my life starts falling apart
i've noticed that too or i mean i
haven't done that program but i think
that is very insightful and i'm starting
to do something similar where i i
journal
now which is like i used to think
journaling was the stupidest thing in
the world i'm also so self-absorbed that
i'm like where in my museum is this
going to go by the way i i saw it i
literally was like you have to journal
for the documentary that's made about
you one day 100
by the way because let me tell you
something i watched the sh the movie bad
vegan or the tv show about vegan yeah i
need water i have thoughts okay bad
vegan i believe that her journal is not
real and that she did it like in the
last couple months i need to watch it
like it's it's like here's my old
journal to show i'm like
all the handwriting is the same it's
bullet points this is a new journal you
just made to pretend to be an old
journal
to
like put in this documentary no that is
constantly that i call bullshit on that
being i need to watch that and i
actually but i believe what you're
saying because that is
my inner psyche while i'm writing is
like where like where are my semantics
i believe all think it will be read one
day when they're famous yeah no one
journals as if it's not going to be
ready i'm going to fight with my father
it'll be like i'm kicking him out of
your exhibit like that's what i like
that is what in it scares him i actually
think it upsets him
but it's just gonna happen i don't know
what to tell you it's not like it's
100 percent it's not about
if it's about when and i mean that's
like
it is weird to go through life like that
but i always used to
oh my god this is so weird i was alone
so much as a kid and i used to pretend i
was always on camera
and it's a weird thing yeah to think
about but i remember being like and it
was a weird like maybe some kind of
survival because i always behaved better
because i was like well i'm on camera
it was a weird scene i know and i don't
know why i just was like i also used to
like
when i was alone i would only eat like
as if i was in a commercial i used to do
that too like
i would read like the box i would roll
up like if i was eating like um cold
cuts i'd roll them up and like eat them
the way i saw them in the oscar meyer
commercial like to practice i would do
that eat like how they do in tv shows
which is like barely any yes totally i
always i mean it was obviously my way of
disassociating but i always like if i
was at thanksgiving or something i
always was like
eating as if i was acting
yeah you're fucking insane
we're taking a real quick break did you
know that with earnest you could change
your interest rate get a lower monthly
payment and you never pay fees not even
late fees that's insane i'm incredulous
did you know that by refinancing you can
reduce your loan terms save money or
combine multiple loans into a simple
monthly payment
i've just blown away that you got that
sentence as stone as you are incredible
with earnest it only takes two minutes
to see what your new rate could be and
there's no credit impact
right now ernest is offering our
listeners a hundred dollar cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
harness.com
whitney
a voice you had in you not available in
all states once again you get a hundred
dollar cash bonus and you visit
earnest.com
to refinance your student loan
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details if you're capable of speaking
like that and you don't do it all the
time not available in all states terms
and conditions apply earn a student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc nmls pound sign one two zero four
nine one seven california financing law
license number six oh five four seven
eight eight five three five mission
street san francisco california 94105
visit earnest.com licenses for a full
list of licenses if you love licenses
back to josie yeah i did so much weird
stuff like that i mean i would think i
was in music videos like stuff like that
but i also would like
if i was like alone walking down a
hallway i was like
walking down the hallway right oh same
music on the playground in elementary
school i was like always in like a
musical i was in like hairspray or
something like the way that i was i'd be
like walking and dancing and like
climbing the monkey bars like i was in a
musical i was like in a scene and glee
and then someone would like punch me and
then
kicked out so i was in a scene in glee
and that's what happened then i was in
glee so maybe i was just manifesting
yeah
but also like um if i was like walking
home i like i also would be in like
horror movies like i like go behind a
tree and like see that would scare me
because i i scare myself i i was in a
horror movie class like this past winter
and they went around the room
and asked everyone what their biggest
fear was and someone was like break-ins
another person was like kidnapping like
they were saying like real rational
things and then they got to me and i was
just like myself
and my professor was truly
concerned and he was like are you well
and i was like is no one else scared of
themselves i am my biggest fear
like what what like i'm i know that i'm
like the most destructive person
in my circle like i could destroy myself
with just the blink of a button do you
ever think that if you're like i don't
know
on live television or something it's
like you could just say one thing awful
in your entire career
yeah yeah right but it's like you almost
it's like standing over the edge of a
cliff and just wanting to jump you know
what it is it's which i do which
so
i love babies i think they're awesome um
really hot takes hot i mean i'm just
saying this is a
i just
sometimes when i'm holding a baby i'm
like what if i just drop this baby
that's a common intrusive thought oh i
actually think about all the time too
like i'm like i'm throwing a joke or
like pushing someone off a subway
platform like yeah stuff like that where
i'm like i could literally just cry like
no no no no no no no no no no no
stylist was telling me that not my
hairstylist i don't know and come from
actual hairstyles but this girl who was
doing my hair in near my school
she was like i was on a walk with my
baby and my baby was crying and i just
and there was a tented house and she was
like just kind of wanted to walk right
into that tented house and see what
happened
and i was like are you okay
she wasn't okay
no so she's dead now i'm fine i'm just
kidding
i used to go um into grocery stores
and um by the way biggest i'm afraid of
grocery stores they scare me
let's get to that but please continue um
uh they
i love them
uh i love them i love grocery stores
because i have such fucked up shit with
like
deading and buying and anytime i buy
someone i buy clothes or anything or
something nice i feel instant regret
i'm the same with that way but with food
i'm like i know this is a good purchase
like anything i buy in this store right
like i'm not a piece of shit that's
overspending and like you know what i'm
like i am i'm not going to have shame
after this but i used to go into grocery
uh grocery stores and go to like the
entenmann's like cake section and walk
by and like punch the cakes like the top
down onto the cakes you are evil
how old were you
you're like this is last week i know
this is
uh yeah well like a kid like i would and
then i would go to like the magic middle
like like the keebler like cookies and
like squish them like through the bag
insanity you just felt like you need to
do something you were daring i don't i
don't know what that was like we ended
up putting it in the roseanne reboot
like uh
uh darlene's daughter was doing it like
just little weird destructive things or
like oh you know what else i used to do
i used to like creatively litter like as
it even when i was alone because i was
like i'd like have gum and i would like
do something where i'd like pretend i
was doing something to throw it in a way
that didn't look like littering but it
was just for me
that is so interesting i feel like we
all have those little things with
ourselves little things we do yeah see
groceries don't scare me because it is
one place where everyone and this is how
i feel about like walking to a class on
campus
everyone seems to know where they're
going what they're doing they know where
everything is every item is in the place
that they know and i just feel like a
deer in the fucking headlights
i feel like dora without like a map or
like a little person by my side telling
me where to go
and it scares me and i'm always bumping
it's like bumper cars i'm bumping into
people because i don't know where to go
and then i end up just going home and
ordering and like wasting my life mine i
love grocery stores because also i it
shocks me like shocks me every time
people don't do things the same way i do
them
like if i look at someone's grocery cart
i'm like
it blows my mind what people like i
cannot
even looking in people's carts
is the mo to me the most entertaining
thing that the most engrossed i can be
it's just like four bubbly pizzas
like snap peas and like what is your
like and trying to figure out your life
i'm upset and i think that's also how i
became a writer in a weird way because i
would like always try to figure out
people's backstories like if i see
strangers i would like start writing
their backstories and how do they know
each other
like
i just love seeing people's weird shit i
love watching women put on makeup every
time
emily
especially like when they're like she
licks the liner before she puts it on
her eye that is such a thing
i also like watching people and i think
that that is certainly i feel like an uh
like a writer thing or like trying to
make up like
why someone got somewhere like teachers
i find very fascinating like you're
committing your life to like just
lecturing these like children in a room
i hate you and you like know that you
know they hate you like i had a
professor last week he like called out
um of going to class because he like
fell and like hit his head and i was
thinking like did anyone respond to this
email
i didn't like i'm sorry that you hit
your head but like i'm not the great
class is over like you know i'm like
they must start like
so
they must be so sad but wait
wait what is he okay
yeah i mean i guess he's fine like we
have class tomorrow night but he just
like was in the hospital or something he
did like a big email saying like i went
to the hospital and like no one
responded yeah i don't think a single
person did
unless it was like a direct response
[Music]
was it bcc or i mean it was everyone was
cc'd yeah no it was like everyone the
only thing worse than someone hitting
their head is having to then check 500
emails
from people that are pretending to care
right right so maybe that was the nicest
thing to possibly know honestly i think
i was just trying to look out for him i
don't know if it was coveted or what but
right when i when kovac kind of started
i was like biking all the time and uh i
fell off my bike and like five people
saw it and no one did anything and i was
just like i'm gonna get up and be fine
but like
i don't know if this is the covet thing
or like don't see i would love that i
don't want i'd be embarrassed if someone
acknowledged my existence if i fell off
a bike
i want them to just walk straight ahead
and not even look at me but i want
someone to just be like to care yeah
like what if it was like what if it was
really bad right well then that's
actually funny have you ever broken any
bones
um
i think i did
i think i sprained or like fractured
but not really i mean i'm not the most
athletic person
um if you can't tell i'm just like i
don't like putting myself
in a way that requires labor or like
physical
exercise i just don't like that stuff
yeah so i don't really break a lot i
don't get i get more you know emotional
i don't know anyone that is uh
like like younger like everyone that i
know that's young has not had physical
injuries i think because when you're you
you old people
i think people used to play outside a
lot when they were younger yeah we are
not legal now
someone went to that's illegal no okay a
woman got went to
got arrested because her kid was playing
across the street in a park and she was
like kind of looking out the window
that is their kids were taking my social
services because the mother let them
walk to school okay well i fully like
kidnapped a kid when i was like six
years old and a go-kart and like
yeah i know so like i don't know and the
police came and just dropped me off at
my mom's house maybe that's why
privilege it probably is also my mom at
another time took me to the police
station was like taking my kid and they
were like this is in daycare
what were you doing i was just pissing
her off that's actually a thing that uh
because you're in southern california
you grew up right no northern california
oh okay i was just gonna say it is a
very southern thing i'm lieutenant you
drop your kid off at the police station
like can you just handle this game yeah
no that is something that my mom did i
was probably like
six or seven and they were like we don't
take children ma'am like please
leave our property my mom is just like
i'm done and i was like negotiating i
was like do you guys have like a day
system or is it like overnight only
what are the accommodations like like is
there amenities here and they're like
this is the police station get the fuck
out of here you fucking idiot that's
kind of how that happens but what what
what is your birth order
my birth order yeah i'm not familiar
with what is your
brother
oh yeah yeah okay so i'm the youngest
okay and my brother is the middle and my
sisters the youngest is um
we just had to raise ourselves like our
parents were done parenting yeah do you
know if you were on purpose
no oh no i was a complete accident i was
born like a decade after my siblings yes
they were like my mom was convinced like
nothing had worked i like it was
breastfed by my mom and it was like
powder came out it was like flower
she was like in her 40s
and i yeah she got pregnant just
naturally uh she nursed she was like 38
i think she nursed me
until i was like four years old i was
like i feel like if your kid can be like
mommy can i have titty like that's
probably a problem but what oh so she
you just kept demanding it i was
obsessed with it
i'm obsessed with it 100 obsessed and my
grandma i would like try on bras as a
kid and my grandma was like you just
love bras because you loved being
breastfed i'm like you stupid fucking
bitch i like want teds and
and how do you know all this do you
remember this i know people are like
when i was three i did this like i don't
remember anything i i have small
memories when i was super young but
before i moved to la before i was 10
years old i don't remember being back
home and even living in l.a as a young
person there's so many people that come
up to me and like apologize to me or
they i think expect me to apologize to
them because like
i did something fucked up to them and
it's like i have no memory of that so i
naturally apologize to every single
person from my childhood right like if
i've met you before that's the first
thing i do and like i'm really close to
like this kid now he's like one of my
best friends and i like bullied him in
middle school but we don't remember what
i did to him he doesn't remember
how he received it feels fair fair's
fair we spent valentine's day together
me and him and his boyfriend it was
wonderful um yeah i just feel like you
know it's like when you
like kids need to work shit out like
bullying like i'm not like hate crime
people bully people but it's like this
is some this is how i mean you see dogs
do it it's like you have to test each
other so if you're unhappy with yourself
you're gonna take it out on other people
and i think at that age especially
everyone coming to move to l.a to like
pursue their dream of acting or whatever
it's like has to hate themselves a
certain amount to have to like have
gotten there yeah of course but also
like be so you go um
like egotistical and like an egomaniac
to like convince themselves that they
could even thrive yeah in a different
state it's a weird it's a weird kind of
self-hating narcissism where you're like
i
believe that i should star in movies but
i also but i also am the worst person on
earth exactly yeah it's like a weird i
found this like the other day i screen
tested for like a very like a legendary
director
and
i was like i'm getting this
yeah and i was like i don't
i don't think the jokes that are working
in my stand up
are f that funny like the way i hate
myself on so many levels but now i had
this like delusional confidence and i
was like you know what i'm so into
delusional confidence now same
so the other shit just didn't serve me
here's the thing with like everyone's
like how do you get high self-esteem
it's not from fucking quotes on
instagram no that shit works it's from
doing receivable actions and then just
realizing getting to a rock bottom going
like you know what it just doesn't serve
me in any way yeah no one likes it it's
uninteresting no one thinks it's cool
yeah it's boring like insecure people
are dangerous yeah like i look at the
people that are killing right now i'm
like these are delusionally confident
people
100 percent and they're kind of might be
talented but like if you think that's
i've been trying to be in that wave too
confidence having a certain amount of
confidence that is like
in equal to
like your actual strengths and talents i
think that was something that
tina fey said once when she like won an
award that she was like grateful that
her parents gave her
like an overwhelming sense of confidence
that did not match like her actual skill
set or like whatever which is like
obviously untrue she's like the most
brilliant person on earth yeah but i was
like that's actually true for me
because i
try to constantly convince myself that
also like people automatically if like
assume that you're cooler you're smarter
and intelligent than you already are
even though in general in general i
think that is something that's a fact
that is something that is i remember my
dad said to me once and i obviously
didn't take any of this advice like
people start like thinking you're
brilliant and everything you say you're
just knocking just say as little as
possible and let people project onto you
and like let be a mirror for their
insecurities you can be a mirror to
someone else's stuff and there's
something nice about like not taking the
bait and like
you know that's my new you it just
you're not a bitch if you're just
listening
yeah and i used to think that that was
like you had to
jump into it
it's like feeling like you are burdened
by the conversation and you have to like
i don't know i also find a lot of people
out you probably get this too like
people come to me a lot with their
problems and like tell me really weird
intimate things about their life because
i think they feel comfortable around me
which i'm grateful for but then it also
feels like i'm constantly burdened and
it's never people i'm close with because
people that i'm really close with
obviously are not overburdening me with
stuff but it's like random people at
parties or something like they feel like
i'm the only person in the world that
they can like tell their trauma to
and then like they've now traumatized me
yeah and i'm like crying in the bathroom
because i'm uncomfortable by you i okay
so there's a thing in 12-step program so
it's like the
like getting sober the wreckage of your
past right so like for example um if
you're in aaa or n a which i'm i'm not
like sober off substances like mine's
allen on the um addicted to people
perfectionism mothering
micromanaging martyring doing things out
of obligation you know you know and um
uh it's super cool uh all the things
that people do on drugs that are
reprehensible i do sober because i think
i'm helping all right so there's
something wreckage of your past so it's
like when people get sober there's a big
like you have to apologize to people you
have to like change your number so drug
dealers aren't going to text you you
have to like delete people black people
stuff like that like there's you know
it's called wreckage of your past and i
found i realized this past week the
wreckage of my past in my thing i'm
recovering from is that i only thought
people ever wanted to be friends with me
or talk to me if i was like useful of
service to them in some way i thought
all my um worth to someone else was
being helpful to them rescuing them
saving them or like being an authority
figure and being useful to them because
like growing up like when you're the
youngest or weren't planned or like
right you had to be useful you had to
earn your keep like and i i have a
really hard time having fun like i get
anxious i'm not having fun enough like
i'm the person the party that just wants
to help clean up and like help like put
the dessert out and cut you know like i
just want to be useful right because i
don't feel like that i'm enough just me
so let me um
my self-esteem is drive through my
productivity even though you're kind of
just being annoying you're that annoying
person that's cleaning things up too
soon right and it's just like no one
like the person who at christmas is
picking up the wrapping paper before
everybody i'm an asshole who like i feel
threatened by that so i would just be
like what the fuck is wrong with you
well then it makes other people be like
oh should we be helping you no just me
like you guys have fun i'm just fucking
but then in my head i see people like
that as like someone who's just like
wants attention
100
and then i get angry and then it's
because i want attention well it's like
i know it's like i'm just like i'm such
a martyr and everyone's like you're so
nice and you get this credit said i hate
that shit if you're at my house doing
that i'm just like what the fuck is
wrong with you get out of the kitchen
i didn't invite you here to clean yeah
you're making and i always find that the
people that do that are the more quiet
ones that like just that's the only way
they see themselves having a purpose is
if they're doing something that's like
actually helping i'm like actually
that's not helping it's gonna be
happening if you start in the corner and
got a fucking conversation like a normal
fucking person well no i would say like
on my gravestone it's just gonna say i
was just trying to help it's like that
is it's like the people that got a
relationship they're like i just loved
too much it's like this is this it's
toxic niceness is what codependence is
right it's like you know what i first
heard when i went to program
people-pleasing is a form of asshole
yeah oh you're just kind of like a needy
annoying kind of domineering it's the
3ms mothering micromanaging monitoring
you're trying to solve before you solve
a problem make sure it's your problem
like when you go into someone's house
like oh hey let me fix that it's just
like i didn't invite you here to shut up
that's so true i know someone like
that's so but you genuinely think you're
being helpful you're being useful and
it's it's also the the people that
constantly ask you if you're okay are
you okay how are you are you okay do you
need anything it's like that's so true
that's so you're trying to get points
for this
asking me if i need anything
no i'm gonna do that because they're
they're just kind of they're
uncomfortable in silence or something or
like they just aren't don't feel like
they're enough in that moment or they
need validation and they're making us
not be equals right now right why are
you doing this
i hate that no no you're not the waiter
but in your mind it's like do you need
anything can i help you are you okay
that's the big i'll let you know if i'm
not like you will know
and what you do what you're saying the
subtext is hey i know you're a liar so i
know i asked you if you're okay but i
know you're not like there's no way you
could be you're a liar
you're accusing me of being dishonest
with my communication yeah and you're
accusing me
of putting my friends to work like
that's like when someone's like do you
want something to eat and you're like no
and they're like you should probably
have something i'm like what you don't
no fucking know me i don't want fucking
food you know and then they like hand me
like a protein bar it's like they need
to feel like they're helping you but
you're being annoying yeah you're
basically saying you're being annoying
and i think you're being exhausting
and you think you need to rescue people
that are just fine yeah which is
judgment you're judging you're like you
would fall apart if it wasn't for me i'm
gonna i'm just gonna 100 too stupid to
take care of yourself so i'm gonna do it
but it is under this guise of like i
really grew up
thinking that that was kind that that
was the nice thing to do you know can i
help can i help with that and then you
just learn being yourself is just a so
much easier and and obviously it's
enough and also like at going to
someone's house for dinner like
now that i'm like an adult and i'll like
have a dinner party i'll have people
over the person that like start gets up
and starts helping i'm like
you don't know where these dishes go i'm
gonna you don't put that food in the
trash i'm gonna give it to the dogs like
i wanna clean up right you know i'm
saying you're taking that from me
because a lot of times people cleaning
up at parties that's their way of
getting a fucking break i went when i
was dating this guy uh uh a couple years
ago i went um it was like his family
doing they do like a yearly reunion and
the husband of the sister
um was like doing the dishes was like
doing all these dishes all these dishes
like tons and i'm like oh my god i'm a
guest here i should go help him whatever
and i went over and i was like hey can i
help you and he was like leave me alone
like this is my time
this is the only time i have like please
don't help me like i need this i'm gonna
use that yeah like you don't take so
long it might be their coping thing they
might have a because then it's like
someone's helping you and like then
you're the cunt because you're like
you're putting in the dishwasher right
that's something i need to trust that
people are more vocal than like we think
that they are and then we don't have to
like read between any lines and like
discover like some sort of like puzzle
like we can just wait to be told that
we're needed if we're needed and also
look at your motive for doing it like
like take a second are you trying to
actually help like i already like you
you're here we're friends right like now
don't yeah are you trying to actually
help and then also it's like because
then the wreckage of my past is this
what you were saying all the people that
i realized because i was last week emily
has known me for so long i i said
something the other day that i've never
literally never said before i was like
i'm having this feeling where like
i feel like i'm just
i
think i'm overwhelmed
and i've never been overwhelmed i've
never i i always like when people say
they're bored or overwhelmed i don't
understand what they're saying because i
i've never chaos is so comfortable to me
like it energizes me like
like i feel comfortable in it i feel
overwhelmed when i have to make certain
decisions like if i have it like four
hours free and i'm like there's nine
things i need to do i'm kind of like
it'll take me a second to choose which
one
but that's not that to me is just like
decision fatigue right i've never been
bored and i've not when people like i
get i'm bored i'm like how can anyone be
bored there's so much to do there's so
much shit to read and learn and like um
but uh i i realized i was getting
overwhelmed because my text messages
half of them are people that are like
hey who's the best dog walker in santa
monica hey who's the best doctor for uh
a weird chin i don't know right that was
weird because i was thinking i was
trying to think of a jaw someone asked
me the other day hey who's the best jaw
surgeon i'm like why why would they ask
you to go to person no people ask me
that show all the time i've done it it's
my fault because i was the person that
would i'd meet someone new from la and
i'm like here's the best doctor here's
the best guy you know what call me if
you need anything i was like i'm the
same with that yeah everyone's and then
i trained people and i signed myself up
for shit like that people say i my texts
literally people it's a number i don't
know i'm like hey so-and-so said you're
the best person to ask about you know
i'm a cupping person all
the time i lit and i'll sign myself up
for things that i like
do not care about you know what's never
happened
i've never given someone the number and
that was the end of the exchange
right then it's well when's the best
time to go is traffic that one if you
answer one question they now you work
for them yeah yeah and they're going to
ask you a million so i'm going tomorrow
what should i do what was your
experience what did this work for you
but what about this person and i'm just
like
like no good deed this is like um
uh one time i was there's something
psychologically about helping someone
like it was like chris rock um said to
me once he was like there's no such
thing as lending money it's only a gift
because it never ends like there no and
he said this to me i was like no i just
want to be the person that's like giving
back all the time but it's never enough
and you're always going to be the
asshole at the end it's like give an
inch take a mile there was this i used
to give out um like free tickets to
shows for people that couldn't afford
tickets and this person and they would
send to an email like
this guy wrote the loveliest email he
was like i was in the war i'm in a
wheelchair
and every line was like this i know
whitney's not reading this like whoever
is reading this for her and i was
reading them i read shit directly all
the time and um
i write back i'm like hey it's me you
got two tickets it was la jolla comedy
store um front row
see you there can't wait you know this
sob store and like he's like oh my god
thank you so much like this is changing
my life i can't believe you responded
you're my hero
and then i was like here's my number if
you have any problems
20 minutes before the show
hey uh i'm gonna be late
uh can you save like a parking spot
outside
what the fuck and i'm like uh
like and then it's like i mean truly the
number of asks were so wild right
skittles on the show i'm gonna start
right at 7 30 or like who's the opener
like it was i mean i have screen grabs
of it it's on a whole old hard drive
because it is so wild um and then comes
in late to the show
uh is heckling me the entire time and uh
i did a joke about how every guy
somewhere in their house or apartment
has a jar full of coins like a bowl of
coins like it's got like a couple
wrappers in it like like a ring of butt
like buttons and uh
he just like went cold and he went
that's so we can pay for your shit
i'm sorry kick him out
it was just like you kicked him out when
you so he they had to remove him i mean
he was such a problem he was like
verbally there's something
psychologically about when you help
someone
they lose respect for you think oh
they're going to gain respect for me 100
that's yeah exactly which is why i
stopped i used to do all that shit all
the time like cover like pick up the
bill but also like help someone with
certain things give people things like
when people send me stuff like i would
just like give it to people and then
like they expect things of you
and then like you said give an inch to
take a mile
it's not it's not it you're right it's a
complete opposite it's like they
actually like you lose value stop
offering things yeah stop being that
person because i just love being like
well
now i'm the opposite where i'm like
you're not fucking getting unless you're
really close to me and you've earned
your place yeah i'm like i won't give
anything because also i i give out like
this is the best doctor this is the and
then i can't fucking get appointments
and then i can't get in whatever but
it's it's just so wild to me
and then oh if their experience goes
poorly that's the other thing is that
your rec i'm recommending the healers
and the therapists and the this and like
well this i don't like the way this
person handle it i'm like i didn't
now i know we're awkward as if i set you
up on a date with someone that was
shitty to you it's like i'm too involved
in your personal life it's just not
appropriate like it's taking me so long
to realize because it's like i and it's
also the same thing i've no i've it's
hard for me to talk to new people so i
just i'm like let's just talk about the
best
everyone wants to know like where's the
best facial what do you use on your
stuff like that and then i'm like oh
i'll send you the link and now i just
volunteered
to take up 40 minutes of my day to send
this person a link and then they get it
and they're like do i use it in the
morning do i also use it at night and i
just work for you now yeah no one's ever
been like got it thanks and that was the
end of the exchange
yeah that is that is it's a violent
habit and yeah i'm glad that people are
like hey they'll send me videos of their
dogs like hey my dog won't do this can
like what should i do i'm like
i
and these are the same people like i
know you're slammed i thought you seem
like you're so busy but like my dog's
not eating like should i so you're just
like what food you're you're missing
like boundaries that's what you need to
put in place i'm now at the point where
i'm just like unmute me
right
all this is on my instagram somewhere
like all these answers are somewhere on
my instagram listen to the podcast if
you want all the like i talk about yeah
just the can you please take your time
to
like give me all the information the
ques
google it
yeah
that's a big red flag for me now is that
people that ask questions that could be
googled what yeah i agree
i 100 agree i feel like people
like it somehow like it's in the era of
technology people get stupider and i'm
just like it's life is so easy babe why
are you burdening me i also probably
have to go soon yes we do have to let
you go i just love you
i'm never going to like hang hang on i
know can we do that yeah let's do that
because i thought this is a toxic trait
of mine it's being like we need to do
something and then not following up but
i actually do want to follow up because
i want to hang out with you yeah i love
you where are you going you're driving
back i love you i have to go to class
what are you studying i'm i'm going to
college i'm going to i'd yeah at 4 p.m
it's just depressing in here town in
orange county
i love you i know pray for me but i love
you and thank you for having me i love
you this was i feel like we're very all
over the place but that's that's that we
that's what we do that's who we are
that's who we are it's fine i think we
need to have a separate show where we
just have topics about but i'm very
insecure about things now not being like
coherent or not finishing a thing and
today i just surrendered with you i
thought it was amazing and i think
people will appreciate that
the surrendering and the joy that we've
created together and
because i i think you're kind of like me
where you weren't bored of what you're
saying halfway i do i get part of my so
i get so bored of myself i never get
bored i get bored when i'm like i'm
going to talk about this and i'm like
nah
yeah we're like constantly bouncing
but that's the only that's why i do so
well with you is because
i also love talking to you because you
have such a good way of like
throwing things everywhere and i also
function in chaos well and you
are like i feel like i'm either the
person who's like the crazy or the
straight man and the thing i feel like
we balance each other out very well in
that way where we trade off sentences
correct that is true and i feel like
that is it's a relaxing thing because
i'm not like
servicing you as a passenger the entire
time you are um
not easy nothing throws you i do well
with people that aren't sensitive and
that nothing throws down right yeah
that's something that's true as well
because i feel no loyalty to the thing i
said or the person i was 10 minutes ago
oh same in fact i am like do not
prosecute me yes sir i'm embarrassed for
her and i've thrown her away and
honestly deport her
yeah it's just like like i just i know i
just said that but now i'm saying this
yeah and i need to just get on board no
nothing okay you can't be doing math
about whatever comes from my dad he
could see someone be like killed in
front of him and
he would just be like okay i love that
like nothing phases you yeah um don't
write elephants say by the bell uh is
you are so fucking good in the show i'm
sure you guys have already seen it if
you're gonna see it um is there it's
coming back
um we don't know we don't know so
hopefully fingers crossed
i feel like i had to say that fingers
crossed sure but no actually yeah
fingers crossed um but that's just what
people say that's why i said that um and
then yeah ending these awkwardly letting
you go uh my brain is a mess today
love you totally fine i love you so much
[Music]
um
[Music]